you've probably seen a lot of the scary
numbers about what's going on with bills
right now i want to just dissect it and
look at what we're actually facing
introducing a little bit of context
because it's important to get context
here and in some ways it's certainly
scary but in other ways you know there
is a little bit of reassuring news
somewhere along the way
we should start with this shouldn't we
this is the price cap from from off gem
uh this is going back to 2009. it's a
weird thing the price cap isn't it you
know we didn't have anything like this
before but it's just kind of a measure
of what the limit they want to be on the
average bill and right now that's 1971
pounds there's no such thing of course
as the average household but that's
that's you know what they see as being
the kind of median household
and now we know that off gem you know
it's been speculated about for quite
some time what the level was going to be
some people thought well originally
people thought it was going to only
going to be about 2 800 pounds that was
last time the obr looked at this the
office of budget responsibility they
said 2 800 pounds in the event
it's up to over 3 500 pounds
3549 pounds
and bear in mind that when the obr was
talking about 2 800 pounds they said
that was going to cause the biggest
squeeze on our disposable income that we
had ever seen on record well
the fact that it's a lot bigger there
that's that's not the most encouraging
sign
neither is the fact that
if you look at what's happening with
futures markets right now because what
this is basically looking at is looking
at wholesale prices adding on a few
other things like that a slight margin
for energy providers but it's mostly
wholesale prices and you can look
through futures markets at what people
are trading the price of energy at and
if you look at it right now
we're talking about kind of crazy days
pricing we're talking about you know the
average bill being up at 5 000 pounds in
january 6 000 pounds over 6 000 pounds
actually uh in april and i mean this
this that is truly terrifying but it
might not happen and you know right now
prices are incredibly high for a few
idiosyncratic reasons it's possible you
know germany's trying to replenish all
of their stories right now as are many
other european countries that's pushing
up prices a lot
so on the one hand it may not be as bad
as that on the other hand
you know if for instance russia were to
stop all its gas coming into europe it
could actually be worse than that
frankly cards on the table so that's
kind of where we are right now but like
i said it's worth just taking a step
back and kind of looking at that
contextually looking at how that factors
into what we're actually spending our
money on and we can do that because
there's quite good data on this by
looking at average weekly spending so
this is data from the ons
i've just picked out three different
income groups here that's the lowest 10
of spenders there on the left-hand side
i'll get out the way so you can see it
uh about 250 45 pounds uh a week there's
weekly spending you've got the middle uh
income there 590 pounds a week then the
highest 1 200 pounds a week now you know
whether or not you spend that much much
a week i don't know but these are
average numbers statistically collected
from quite a big sample pool and what
you can do which is interesting is just
look at the different slices and where
they come from so for instance
income tax national insurance makes up
quite a big chunk a very big chunk
actually for of of the highest income
people the highest spenders uh for the
middle incomes less so and for lowest
incomes people who aren't necessarily
paying income taxes it basically doesn't
show up much at all or for instance look
at transport so that's quite a big thing
cars fares that cost quite a lot and
just take note of the scale the size of
these these slices as we go through food
and drinks you know another staple
really important by the way that's gone
down so much in terms of how much we pay
as a percentage food and drinks become a
lot cheaper recently which is another
unheld story but energy that you know
where we're heading really that's energy
i've made them red so you can see them
just about see them but what you might
know is they are actually relatively
small aren't they these slices and so
what i'm going to do is just kind of
take all each of these bars and i'll
change them into proportions so it's the
same numbers but we're just looking at a
percentage so what's the percentage of
their spending uh for diff these
different groups that's going on
electricity and gas and you can see for
the lowest income group the lowest
income 10 percent you're talking about
you know a bigger chunk it's kind of
getting towards 10 percent uh at the
moment i say at the moment this is 20 19
20. that was with the latest figures
that didn't get kind of messed around
with by coved so 20 19 20 is what we're
looking at here
which raises the question what does it
look like now and i've kind of
calculated that
and here's where we are now look at
those red bars a little bit bigger okay
so that's based on 1 971 pounds
of bills what happens if we get well
it's not if any more what happens when
uh that uh increase that off gems now
announce kicks in in october well here's
where those bars go look you can see
they're getting bigger every time and
the chunk that we're having to spend on
energy uh gets bigger each time as well
however there's a big proviso here the
government has stepped in they've
stepped in with quite a lot of money
especially for lower income groups
and if you look at what happens of those
lower inco particularly with that kind
of lower spending 10 percent uh if you
factor in the government's intervention
well look the bar gets a little bit
smaller
now that's that's kind of you know does
show that it's not having no impact
whatsoever the government grants right
now actually they have quite a big
impact for certain groups however uh
that's still pretty big
final point though i showed you a moment
ago what happens you know maybe in the
future if those bills do go up to 5 000
pounds well what would happen to these
bars in other words what would happen to
the red bit the bit we spend our energy
on
if we do go into that terrifying world
next year well look at look at the red
bars
i find that you know pretty startling to
be honest with you you're talking and
that's after government the you know
government intervention we've got right
now so that's after the grants we've got
right now for the lowest income groups
we're talking about 40 of spending it's
it's totally
not just unprecedented but it's almost
unimaginable because you've got to think
about the rest of this bar is where all
the rest of your spending is coming from
food shelter everything else
is in that little bit well that bit
that's basically
increasingly squeezed by energy and bear
in mind all of those other costs in the
blue bits are going up right now because
food's getting more expensive rent's
getting more expensive interest rates
are going up too
also taxes by the way as well although
we'll see uh what liz trusts uh only
british sooner want to do about that but
nonetheless
you know you can see in context here
energy going from being a tiny slice
or a small slice rather to a very big
and quite terrifying slice however what
we really need to do is work out how
this compares with historical context so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take that middle red slice and kind of
throw it back through history okay so
the higher this line is i've turned it
into line chalk so we're going back
three times but it's a show in the line
job anyway the the higher that is the
more we are spending as a chunk as a
proportion of our total spending on
energy so that's energy going back to
the 1950s this is 1957 this starts and
what you can probably make out is over
this period
it's been constrained around that range
between six percent uh and about kind of
four percent three percent and what you
might also make out is look more
recently in the 90s and the 2000s
actually energy was pretty cheap
compared with certainly where it was now
but also compared with where it was
before
but here's what happens next okay look
at what happens when this latest
increase kicks in in october look at
that bar
look at that
up to the highest level on record now
quick proviso an important proviso i
haven't yet factored in the government
intervention so when you factor in the
government grants that are going to come
to households around the country 400
pounds for everyone but also more for
those on means-tested benefits
that goes down okay so the bar is still
going up
and it's still actually the highest it's
been since the 1950s but nonetheless uh
it is lower than it would have been
otherwise however if you that do have
those increases we were talking about
the scary increases next year that might
not happen but who knows
just look
up to the highest level i mean you know
it's just totally totally unprecedented
this is back to the 1950s it includes
the 50s includes the 1970s and all those
energy price shocks slightly different
things but nonetheless
when people talk about unprecedented
this is you know the chart that's worth
just bearing in mind which of course
raises the the final question
what next what's the government or
indeed anyone going to do about this
and if we can have a look as i mentioned
you know they have done something
they've spent about 30 billion pounds on
those grants which will as i showed you
make quite a big difference with at
least this next increase if it may not
necessarily mean it's not the the
highest we've ever had ever had but it's
still it helps that cost 30 billion
pounds
which to put it into context his
furlough that's the furlough scheme
about 50 billion pounds a year
what would it cost if you wanted to
freeze the bills where they are now when
i say now i mean at that 1971 so before
october freeze them now here's how much
it would cost if bills
were supposed to go up to what they're
going up to in october in other words if
the kind of levels stay around that
off-gem level of 3400
whatever it was look about 42 billion
pounds it costs a lot of money it will
cost a lot of money to freeze bills
based on where they are heading in the
next few months
about 42 billion pounds
what if those forecasts or projections
are right and the bills are going to go
up potentially to 5 600 pounds what
would it cost for the government to
freeze bills have a look at these bars
have a look at the red bar
that's going up above furlough there
and if they get up to above six thousand
pounds you are talking about
120 billion maybe 130 billion pounds of
government spending bringing government
spending giving bringing the national
debt up to potentially well over 100
of gdp
you know it's crazy territory and it's
scary territory so i'm afraid you know
there's not all that much good news
there was a bit of good news but for the
most part you know i'm just taken by how
consequential this will be for all of us
but also potentially for the public
finances uh as well so that's where we
are right now we'll bring more to you as
we get it and more analysis of course
all on sky news
on our website and here on youtube as
well